u.s mayor in missouri in cool valley
missouri jason stewart he has now
finally got the funding for his project
1.5 million dollars where he is going to
take 1 000 of bitcoin and he's gonna pay
it to his 1500 residents so it's a very
small town cool valley cool name cool
town uh but he's got 1.5 million dollars
he's going to hand out to all of the
different residents in his city but
there's a couple of catches there's a
great photo by the way by from bitcoin
magazine the catch is that he originally
started with 500 now he's got a thousand
you don't just get three thousand
dollars though right john what do you
got to do to get a thousand bucks so
there's a few different requirements
that he's already laid out and i'm sure
he'll implement more but one of the
requirements is there's a vesting period
of five years that you have to hold the
bitcoin for so you cannot sell within
that five years there's also an
educational component um it's very
unclear what that educational component
will actually be but you have to educate
yourself on bitcoin um i don't think
there's gonna be like a quiz or anything
like that at the end but he wants you he
wants you to get educated on the asset
and then um besides other requirements
there's also kind of like a good tax you
would say right so you have a
responsibility to the community you have
to go out and do a social good in the
community and he left he said that he
left that very vague for a reason so
anything from pick up trash to donate to
a museum pretty much anything just like
enhance the community in a good manner
you got to be a noted good person in
order to get the thousand dollars in
bitcoin you get the bitcoin for free you
just got to do a good task someone does
a good task in the community they are
now eligible to go ahead and do it
there's a five-year vesting period so
you can't just get it and immediately
sell it for dollars uh and on top of
that you got the education requirement
as well we've got a couple of quotes
here from the mayor the first one is
quote what really excites me and what
i'm working on is getting regular people
to hold bitcoin and for them to really
benefit from the appreciation of holding
an asset like that obviously he's got a
dope photo to go along with it is that
what you're laughing at pelina i just
like it and the fact that he's the mayor
of cool valley like really bring in the
heat
he's like
he looks cool he's got laser eyes i mean
the guy just gets it we should get him
on the show second quote that he has
here is he says quote it gives me a hope
and an optimism that we can overcome
some of the worst parts of the system
that we're born into and actually create
a future exactly how we want it to be
there's a certain level of hope and
optimism that i get from bitcoin great
great perspective and then the last
quote we have is bitcoin is
fundamentally american it is the most
american thing our government is built
on freedom and personal liberty and
rights and self-sovereignty and all the
things that bitcoin really is i think
it's a natural marriage that bitcoin in
america will thrive this guy gets it and
now not only does the mayor of cool
valley missouri get it on top of that
the citizens of cool valley missouri
will each be getting a thousand dollars
in bitcoin in order to hold it for the
next five years this is what i'm talking
about when we talk about politics we do
a lot of calling out the nonsense on
this show we do a lot of explaining when
people screw up or say stupid things or
do things that are negligible or even
adversarial to citizens
this guy wins the he wins the trophy for
the week in terms of a politician who
gets it and is doing something to
specifically help the people that he is
there to govern he's been the mayor
since june 2020 has taken this small
town in
basically outside of st louis in rural
missouri into international recognition
by what he's doing to the citizens um
just outside of hell we should get him
on the show bitcoin's good for business
right of course do we think that he
watched your
uh episode with francis suarez and he
was like hey cool valley hey you cool
cats and kittens
nobody got that
we all got it don't worry we all got it
all right so my other favorite part
about him is that his twitter bio is
just says small town mayor like that is
the entire bio he's following zero
people and he has 410 followers so maybe
what we should do here is he joined just
recently in uh september of 2021 i
actually
don't know i do think that it is him but
i don't want to have us all tweeted him
because it might not be him so we'll do
our best to get him on the show i think
it'd be cool to get him on here and see
what uh see what he's got to say but i
just want to call out that uh if you are
a politician and you want to benefit the
citizens in your community there are
things that you can do that help them
and there are things you can do to hurt
them
advocating for stupid ideas like
unrealized capital gains uh taxes that
doesn't help but being able to say you
know what we're gonna do is we're gonna
actually work to raise capital and then
we're gonna hand you a thousand dollars
of an asset that is created and
structured in a way that should
appreciate over time so that we can
actually give you a financial tool
pretty damn cool in mind well i think
also it's gonna open up the education
door for a lot of people right that just
didn't understand her to know about it
before and this is going to force them
to go whether it's just simple as
googling it and learning a little more
or reading about what it is or how they
can access it or actually going down the
rabbit hole and figuring it out for
themselves one thing he mentioned was
that obvi uh not obviously but the
younger citizens kind of younger
citizens already some of them already
have bitcoin some of them definitely
know about it but the older ones were
the ones that were just like a little
confused on what was happening what the
asset is uh that's where the educational
gap i think is gonna be very beneficial
is to those older citizens i say it all
the time bitcoin taught me economics and
bitcoin taught me personal finance and
now bitcoin is teaching me politics
right when you hold this asset there's a
very unique uh aspect where it touches
so many different disciplines that you
have to become uh well-educated doesn't
mean that you become an expert by any
means i'm still learning just as much as
everybody else is but you definitely get
educated on all these different types of
disciplines and
one not only is it good from an
education standpoint but two is it
bleeds into other parts of your life
right you start to look at other types
of investment you start to look at other
decisions you make in your life and
you're just more well-rounded because of
it so i looked up the demographics of
cool valley missouri has a population of
1 000
150 people uh was that right it's got
like 1500 people yeah with a
median age of 40.7 years old and a
median household income of 51 000
so this is really interesting i think
it's a no-brainer what's up guys bang
bang thanks so much for watching the
best business show today if we're going
to be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more of the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]